[موسيقى]
بورصه فوكس وانجليزي
الى امبراطوريه الغرب وممالكه كان اتباع
المسيح في الشرق الاوسط وبلاد العرب وصولا
الى بعض مناطق شمال افريقيا من اصحاب
الارض بنو فيها كنائهم ودورا عباداتهم
وعاشوا وتعايشوا مع الاخرين
مر الزمان وتحول المسيحيون الى اقليه في
مهدي ديانتهم لكن كيف ومتى حصل هذا الامر
ولماذا هاجر او هجر سكان الارض الاصليين
هل هو الاضطهاد ام النزاعات الاهليه هل هي
الاحوال الاقتصاديه المترديه هل هي
السياسات الغربيه ازاء من بات اقليات ام
هو انزلاق الانظمه العربيه الحديثه في دول
دساتيرها تبنت الاسلام ديانه رسميه في فلك
الممنوع
في مصر جزيره
الاغنياء بيتعايشوا اللي خلاني اسيب مصر
وهو من زمان وانا اتولدت عندي الفكره من
اول ما كبرت ان انا ما ليش مكان في البلد
دي ابتديت احس بعد ما وديت جيش ان هي مش
بلدي اول موقف اضطهاد تعرضت له يعني في
حياتي تقريبا وانا صغير كان عندي 10 سنين
في فريق المدرسه اختروني كنت بلعب كويس
جدا فلما عرف ان انا مسيحي همم طلعني من
فريق المدرسه فابتديت احس بقيمتي ان انا
اقل من الناس بالنسبه لي يعني اعرف وضع
كويس ان انا مسيحي ما ليش حقي كثير في
البلد همم ما احلامش قوي يعني كان في بعض
المدرسين اللي بيتعاملوا معنا بعنصريه
عشان احنا مسيحيين وخصوصا في كان احنا
مجبرين في التعليم اللغه العربيه ان احنا
لازم نحفظ النصوص القرانيه كان بيبقى صعب
بالنسبه لنا وهم يتابعوا كده ان هم لازم
يحفظه وما تنجحش عشان ماده اللغه العربيه
الا لما تحفظ النصوص القرانيه اللي هي
اصلا بتهاجم عقده اللي انا ابتديت
استوعبها همم عيب بقى في الشارع برده كان
همم يا غالي اصحابي بعد منهم مش كلهم
بالامانه ما رضيوش يخليني العب معهم وكده
يقول لك لا ما تلعبش مع الولد ده الولد ده
قصراني وكده طبعا لحد ما كبرت كان موجود
لكن في شويه في الجيش من بعض الناس في
الجيش كان في التهاود اا كان في في وظائف
شغل او حاجه زي كده كان موجود اللي يتحمل
المسؤوليه طبعا انا اصغر ونشوف يعني انا
اسف لما انت في حديث صحيح في الاسلام
حتى يشهدوا بالنا لا اله الا الله وان
محمد رسول الله فقال لهم عصموا مني دماغه
فانت مستنيه ايه من المسلم اللي لسه ماشي
بيتعلم في المدرسه انت من منتظره من وين
انا مش بعتبر نفسي ان انا ان انا عربي انا
بعتبر نفسي ان انا مصري قبطي انا اصلا مش
عربي انا داخل علي عمرو بن العاص دخل علي
بالسيف فرض علي الاسلام على جدودي اللي
كان معه فلوس دافعه فيزياء واللي ما كانش
معه فلوس ما دفعش جنسي اصلا اوتلر
[موسيقى]
قبطي لم يكشف عن هويته خوفا من التبعته
الدول العربيه
اهلا بك من حيث سيدني هل يشعر اليوم كل
المسيحيين في الدول العربيه بالاضطهاد
بشكل متساوي ومن يضطهدهم فعليا
من غير همم
الحق ان انعمم ظاهره الاضطهاد على كل
البلدان العربيه وغيرها هذه ظاهره همم
المطاطيه مرنه بمعنى انها تحصل في بعض
الحالات في بعض الاماكن في ظروف معينه
هناك مؤثرات داخليه هناك مؤثرات خارجيه
هناك همم يعني اسباب
تتعلق بهذا الطرف اسامه اخرى تتعلق بطرف
اخر من الصعب ان يعني نشير بالاصبع الى
تعريف ثابت لحاله الاضطهاد اذا كانت
موجوده بهذا الشكل وبهذا المقياس لكن بدون
ادنى شك ان هناك سلوكيات بين اقول هناك
سلوكيات مؤسسه احيانا على همم عقيده
احيانا المؤسسه مؤسسه السلوك على همم حدث
معين او على اشاعه معينه او على نقص في
التربيه وانا هنا يعني اشير الى انه
التربيه في البلدان العربيه بحاجه الى
اعاده نظر من جديد وخصوصا مناهج التعليم
في فتره التاريخيه معينه في العالم العربي
اليوم المناهج التعليميه بغالبيتها العظمى
انا شخصيا اطلعت بالحد الادنى على مناهج
ال ال الادبيات التاريخ الجغرافيا التربيه
المدنيه اللغه العربيه وسواها وانا ارى ان
هناك حاجه ملحه وحاجه ضروريه الى احداث
نقله النوعيه كبيره جدا
لادخال هذه المناهج في بوققه جديده معاصره
تحاكي الانسان كاسان وليس الانسان
بانتمائه العرقي او الهويات او الجنس والى
اخره
هذا ما تحتاج الى ايه مناهج التربيه
والتعليم اولا وقبل كل شيء وحتى قبل ان
اتحدث عن الاضطهاد واشكال الملاحقات
والمضايقات وما اشبه ذلك شكرا لك هيبقى
معنا سيدي همم يرحب من اربيل برئيس طائفه
السريان الارثوذكس في الموصل واكلين
كردستان العراق
متى اهلا بك سيد يعتبر كثر من الخبراء في
المنطقه والمؤرخين منهم ان الاضطهاد في
الدول العربيه مشترك بين كل طوائف والوان
في المجتمعات المقيمه ولا يعني
المسيحيين فقط ما رايك بهذه النظره طبعا
اكيد همم يختلف الموضوع مثل ما قال السيد
جوني قبل قليل من منطقه الى اخرى التعميم
هو ليس بشيء
الايجابي لكن بصراحه
همم
الاضطهاد هو
موجود لا نقدر ان همم
مثل ما نقول نتخبى خلف اصبعنا الاضطهاد
واضح
للاقليات وهذا يعتمد على مدى همم ثقافه
المجتمع وقبول من الاخر وهذا يتركز ايضا
على نوع همم ما يدرس في المدارس
وليس كمنهج دراسي فقط بل كاسات ذا يقدمون
هذا المنهج الدراسي وطريقه تقديم لهذا
المنهج الدراسي
اليوم يعانون من اضطهاد لسبب واضح همم قله
عدد
المسيحي في ال- في الامور الطبيعيه في
الحاله الطبيعيه
يستطيع ان يعيش ويثمر ويطور في كل مكان
يكون فيه القانون هو السائد ولهذا اليوم
كمثال اليوم العراق
يختلف ااا حياه تختلف حياه المسيحي من
العراق الى اقليم كردستان مثلا في بقيه
مناطق العراق المسيحي يعاني ويتعب ويشعر
بقليته بالفعل بعكس ما هو موجود في
كردستان التي تسعى دائما لان تعطي صوره
مختلفه للمنطقه كلها وليس من العراق فقط
مدى المواطنه والمساهمه في بناء الوطن
وليس على بناء على عدده وكميته
واقليه او اكثريه
بصراحه هو مبدا مهين للانسان والانسانيه
رنا سويس اهلا بك رنا عملتي منذ سنوات على
تحقيق حول ميراث المسيحيين في الاردن
حول التمييز في هذا الشان اليوم هل يعاني
المسيحيون من التمييز على المستوى
القانوني والدستوري في الدول تتبع الشريعه
الاسلاميه او تستوحد ساترها من الشريعه
الاسلاميه اكيد في قوانين همم تميز ضد
المراه
وقوانين تميز ضد الاقليات ايضا ولكن في
يجب ان نعترف ان هناك في همم يعني همم
صراع داخلي ايضا بين المسيحيين نفسه مثلا
بالاردن بالنسبه للميراث هنا يعني بعض همم
رؤساء ورجال دين وغيرهم همم ومواطنين
المسيحيين ضد تغيير همم قانون الميراث في
الاردن
والمساواه ويوجد هناك الاكثريه الذين
يريدون تغيير القانون وهذا ليس همم يعني
حكوا الحكومه الاردنيه
وبعدين نقدر نغير القانون لكم ولكن ليس
هناك اتفاق لحتى اليوم نعم همم
وليس نابع من الدوله نابع من البيئه من
التعليم اااه من عدم تقبل الاخر همم من
الافكار التطرفيه اي اين ما كانت يعني همم
افكار همم يعني همم متطرفه من اي جهه والى
اي همم مكان يعني همم ليس فقط ضد
المسيحيين لكن ضد ضد الاخر ضد الاقليه
يعني ما يحصل المسيحيين اليوم ربما قد
يجسد ماساه هذه المنطقه بشكل عام 100%
وبحب احكي هون عن هجره المسيحيين همم يعني
احنا بنشوف انه الاردن مثلا ليس بلد فيها
حروب ولا نزاعات لكن اعداد المسيحيين همم
خلال سنوات الباديه همم تقل وتقل وتقل
ولكن الاسباب عده وهي يعني بعضها همم هو
الحاله الاقتصاديه البطاله اييه والعيش
الافضل في
بلاد ثانيه وايضا العداله يعني ممكن ايضا
الشباب الاردنيين المسلمين ايضا في بعض
منهم يريدون ان يهاجروا لاسباب اقتصاديه
ايضا في نقطه مهمه همم صار في تحول وهي
دخول داعش على المنطقه في 2014 وهذا فعلا
كان له تاثير في الخوف لانه كان همم يعني
همم
مستهدفين الاقليات ليس فقط المسيحيين يعني
راينا ايضا اليزيديين واخرين الاستهداف
الاخر قبل ان نتعرف على ضيفنا الاخير في
الاستديو حضره المطران الاشرت الى فكره
مهمه اليوم هناك رفض ربما من بعض
المسيحيين الى همم قول اليوم ان المسيحيين
في في منطقه الشرق والدول العالم العربي
هم اقليه لماذا همم رفض هذا التعبير وايضا
كيف تجيب على مساله هل بالنسبه اليك هناك
نقطه تحول في همم في ما بعد عام 2014 مع
مع ظهور تنظيمات الارهابيه مثل تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه
وهل برايك هذا يؤثر فقط على المسيحيين ام
ان ايضا هذه التنظيمات يعني قتلت كل كل
الناس يعني وليس فقط المسيحيين والاقليات
الاخرى همم مره اخرى اقول انه تعبير
اقليات اقليه واغلبيه هو همم تعبير او
مصطلح مهين للانسان كالانسان لان الانسان
لا يقاس بعدد همم افراده لان هو ليس قطيع
من الاغنام ابدا
لا انا مو اقصد انت انا اقصد بصوره عامه
لا لا اكيد بصوره عامه اليوم صار يستخدم
هذا المصطلح الاقليه والاغلبيه مجرد وجود
هذا المصطلح يعطي شعور للمستمع انه اقل من
غيره بامور كثيره ولكن بصراحه الانسان
يقاس لما قدمه للمجتمع لما قدمه للاخر
هكذا يقاس الانسان فلو كان عدد واحد ولو
كان عدد عده ملايين همم العدد هو ليس مهم
بقدر ما يقدم هذا الانسان لمجتمعه اليوم
المسيحي في هذا الشرط رغم قله عدده واللي
عدده بلش يتناقص من 1400 سنه في هذا الشرق
ليس الان فقط بلش يتناقص كثير همم لكن رغم
هذا مستمر المسيحي في ان يقدم الصوره
الاجمل للانسانيه ولبناء الوطن الذي يعيش
به لايمانه الكامل بالمواطنه ما يؤثر على
المسيحي في وجوده في هذا الشرق هو سلطه
القانون همم
المدرسه رقم اثنين لان في المكان المسيحي
لا يستطيع ان يعيش في المكان الذي لا يكون
القانون هو الذي يحكم مثلما حدث بالعراق
ليس فقط في 2014 لكن احنا من 2003 الى
2014 احنا كمسيحيين يعطيك مثال
كمسيحيين في العراق قبل 2003 كان العدد
اكثر من مليون و600,000 من 2003 الى 2014
العدد نزل الى النصف مليون وهاليوم بعد
اقل من النصف مليون هذا كله بسببه بغياب
القانون لا يوجد قانون لان ثقافه المسيحي
نحن تربينا مع الاسف لم نتربع صرنا نقول
مع الاسف ولو المفروض افتخر في هذا الشيء
نحن لم نتربع على ثقافه القتل لم نتربع
على ثقافه الغزو لم نتربع على ثقافه الغاء
الاخر بل على ثقافه بناء وتطوير ومحبه
الاخر لكن اليوم الاخر في الوطن العربي اه
تعتبر ان الاغلبيه لديها ثقافه قتل اليوم
ولكن اليس ظلما ربما
لاشخاص كثيره
ليست الجميع ليس الجميع لا نستطيع ان نعمه
اكيد لا نستطيع ان نعمن لكن اليوم هذه
الثقافه اصبحت منتشره والدليل انه لما اجت
داعش انا من الموصل وابن الموصل ومطران
الموصل وكان لما تركته الموصل كان بيني
وبين داعش فقد ثلاثه ام 100 متر همم لما
جاءت داعش للموصل كان هنالك حاضنا لها مع
الاسف كان هنالك حاضنه كان هنالك من
استقبلها اكيد كان هنالك ايضا مره رفضها
ولكن كانت اصواتهم جدا قليله تعظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه قتل المسلمين ايضا يعني لم يقتل
فقط مسيحيين قتل مستعان قتلوا كل من قال
له نعم قتل نعم قتل كل من قال له لا قتل
كل من قال له لا ولكن ال- ال- الموضوع
يفرق لما نحنا يكون
وجودنا قليل فيها هذه المنطقه فنتاثر
تاثرنا ليس كتاثر غيرنا هذا الموضوع طيب
ونحن مع الاسد
الدول العربيه يعني ابقى عند هذه الفكره
ساعود الى كحدث مطران فقط لنتعرف على
ضيفنا الرابع في الاستوديو هنا همم شرسه
صحفي ومسؤول تواصل باللغه العربيه في مهل
العالم العربي باريس اهلا بك همم
عندي سؤال يعني اليوم تحدث عن حضره
المطران عن سلطه القانون تحدث سيد جونيا
عند الاضطهاض لا يختلف من دولار الاخرى
اللبناني ربما هناك مثال ايضا في لبنان
على دوله يشارك فيها المسيحيون بشكل مباشر
في الحكم وبالتالي اليوم
ما نتحدث عن الجدل حول مسيحيين ما يعرف
المسيحي الشرق هناك جدل حوله هويه ايضا
المسيحيين يطرح في الدول العربيه بعضهم
يجاهر بهويته العربيه اخرون يرفضون ان
يطلق عليهم مسيحيين عرب
انت اليوم همم هل تعتبر ان التوجه ربما
نحو الغرب جعل للمسيحيين امتيازات معينه
جعلهم ربما همم هل فعلا تجهوا الى الغرب
اصلا
عائده الى مساله تعريف الهويه العربيه ما
هي الهويه العربيه انا برايي الشخصي هي
هويه لغويه بدرجه الاولى حاضنه للثقافه
ابعد من مساله الدين ولو ان الدين
الاسلامي والحكم الاسلامي في زمن الخلافه
الامويه والخلافه العباسيه تحديدا ساهم في
انتشار هذه اللغه على مساحه جغرافيه واسعه
في هذه المنطقه انما العربيه كهويه
للمسيحيين مشاركات حاسمه في نهبطها
فابقائها على قيد الحياه منذ ما قبل
الاسلام
والقبائل العربيه من تغلب والغساسنه
والمناذره الى الشعراء امرؤ القيس حاتم
الطائي هؤلاء كلهم عرب اضافه الى مساهمات
السوريان في العربيه من بيت الحكمه في زمن
الخلافه العباسيه ورغم ان السوريان ليسوا
من شبه الجزيره العربيه او اثنيا هم عرب
وانما هم مشاركون فعليا في
الثقافه العربيه الى ذلك في القرن السادس
عشر والسابعشر كان لي البطركيات المسيحيه
في المشرق العربي دور حاسم في طباعه الكتب
العربيه
وابقاء العربيه حيه في زمن
اليوم عندما ناخذ هذا التعريف حول الهويه
العربيه يصبح الموضوع سهلا بالنسبه
للمسيحيين وبالنسبه للاخرين اما اذا حصرنا
طب المنطق الديني فهناك همم يصبح الاسلامي
وعربي هذه هي المشكله
الحقيقيه لذلك همم اليوم المشكله هي لدى
همم كثير من المسلمين وايضا المشكله لدى
المسيحيين الشرقيين ومنهم عربا وارما
وسريان
والى اخره اما في في المساله التي كنت
اسمعها من
المشاركين الكرام همم اليوم المساله ليست
جديده والمساله ليست محصوره في المسيحيين
فكلنا في الهم شرق وكما يقال اليوم في
الدول العربيه بمعنى ان همم الامن همم
معدوم او ضعيف في كثير من الدول على
الجميع والحريه ايضا ليست همم فقط تتعرض
للمسيحيين كما ان مساله التنميه
الاجتماعيه
المعدومه وليست كيف في كافه الدول ليست
همم حكرا على المسيحيين اما المسيحيون
اليوم اكثر ممن يعاني من هذه المساله نظرا
الى اعدادهم التي لم تعد تحتمل مساله
الهجره الكثيفه وللمفارقه اليوم ان الهجره
لم تعد الى دول اوروبيه كما ذكرت سيده او
دول ذات طابع المسيحي اليوم اللبنانيون
المسيحيون الذين يحضون برئاسه مسيحيه عرفه
يهاجرون الى دوله يحكمها الشارع الاسلامي
وحكمها خادم الحرمين الشريفين
نموذج التنميه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
فلذلك
يجب همم
التفريق هنا بين مراحل همم وجغرافيا
لانهم غرباء في اوطانهم هناك ايضا شعور
بعدم الثقه بالنفس
يختلف من منطقه الى اخرى ومن بلد الى اخر
لا استطيع ان الوم ابن طور عبدين او سهل
نينا او الجزيره الفراتيه عندما دخلت داعش
على عدم الشعور بثقه بالنفس فهذا شيء
طبيعي ولكني الوم شخصا همم لا يتعرض اليوم
لخطر امني ولا يتعرض لخطر همم لخطر همم
عدم استقرار
ويعيش في حاله اقتصاديه جيده نوعا ما
ولكنه يفضل الهجره الى الغرب لانه يعتبر
نفسه اقرب بالموضوع الثقافي وهذه مساله
ايضا ذات تاثيرات تاريخيه
هل تعتبر اليوم ان يعني هل يمكن ان يفسر
ان المسيحي او المسيحيه في في دول من
العربي يمكن ان يكون اقرب الى الغرب منه
الى الثقافه التي ينتمي اليها في دولته او
التي ولد فيها
مساله محليه اولا وثانيا الثقافه ايضا
الوافده هناك نحن نعلم انه منذ عده قرون
وبوجه خاص منذ القرن 19 عددا كبيرا من
المؤسسات التبشيريه الغربيه بوجه خاص سواء
كانت تتحدثنا عن همم الكاثوليكيه
بالرهبانيات المختلفه التي تغلغلت في
سوريا وفي لبنان وفي فلسطين وفي العراق
وفي مصر والى اخره اضافه الى همم المؤسسات
التبشيريه الارثوذكسيه وفي مقدمتها
القيصريه الروسيه التي كان لها شبكه من
المدارس والمؤسسات في هذه المنطقه هذه
تركتر كبير جدا بدون ان نشاكل لكن لا
نستطيع نحن ان نقول بان المسيحي في المشرق
لديهم توجهات فقط نحو الثقافه الغربيه بل
بالعكس في القرن التاسع عشر مع ارتفاع
منسوب التوجهات اللي توجهات التيارات
القوميه في العالم الغربي بوجه خاص
وارتفاع منسوبها ايضا هذا ترك اثرا كبيرا
جدا على عدد من النخبه المثقفه المسيحيه
وكان في بلاد الشام او في مصر بوجه خاص
على الدعوه الى ما يوحد العرب ككل وانا قد
اتفق انه ظاهره اللغه هي ظاهره موحده لكن
هي ليس فقط الوحيده هناك ايضا التاريخ
المشترك وهناك الكثير من التاريخ المشترك
بين ابناء هذه المنطقه سواء كانوا من
المسيحيين او من المسلمين هذا ما بحث عنه
رواد النهضه العربيه في القرن التاسع عشر
ومطلع ال20 ما يوحد بين
العربدين ان يعني همم المناظرين لم بتاعه
القوميه العربيه كانوا من المسيحيين في في
منطقه الشمس
الى كيف ترى الغالبيه المسلمه شركائها
وشركاتها في الاوطان من الطوائف المسيحيه
نستمع الى اجوبه الموازين المواطنات في
مختلف الدول العربيه
اتمنى اتمنى انهم يفتحون باب الهجره
للمسيحيين اتمنى
لانه عنجد في في مضاياههم
يا ماما الله يرحمها كانت مسيحيه واسلمت
وما في فرق بيناتنا يعني لا بالتعامل بين
القرايب ولا بره ولا جوه بالعكس اللي
تراهم ممكن عبيدوخلي بالفعل انا وهو ما
اكتسحوا المجلات الفنيه واختلوا الفرص
اللي بتاع السفمار
من الاسلام السياسي
والشعب المصري او الشعب العربي ده كله
انما اضطهاد
اخواته ما بنفكرش في الدين اصلا كل واحد
دينه لنفسه بس اه في دول قائمه على
الاضطهاد ومش شرط الاضطهاد يكون اضطهاد
للمسيحيين بنشوف دول كمان المسلمين فيها
ربما اريد احسن
الاساس بلبنان هالحقيقه
بدل المسيحيه بلبنان ما بسوى لبنان
احنا موجود عندنا احتلال موجود عندنا يعني
نوع من حب البلد حب الوطن هم عايشين زينا
زيهم همم
هذا بس العنصريين اللي بره عشان يخربوا
علينا البلاد هذه القصه كلها يما ولا كلنا
اهلنا وحبايب
حضرتك
السؤال الذي يطرح الان اليوم مثلا في
لبنان يقول لك الكثير من اللبنانيين انه
ما في لبنان بدون مسيحيين يعني لا طعم له
ربما كبلد لماذا هل هناك تفريغ ربما منهج
لهذه الطوائف الموجوده في هذه المنطقه لكي
تتحول هذه الدول الى دول من ذات لون واحد
واذا هذا واذا كان هذا الامر صحيح من يريد
هذه
ان ان تقع هذه الامور برايك مثل ما قلت
هذا الكلام الوردي هو جدا جميل والناس
البساطه دائما ما يعرفون همم خفايا الامور
واحنا دائما نسمع هذه العبارات الجميله
انتم الاصل انتم الاهل انتم الجمال انتم
الورود انتم كل شيء جميل لكن لما نجي على
الحقيقه الواقعيه نشوف هذا الشيء هو ما
موجود همم نحنا بصراحه همم اليوم انا احكي
بالنسبه للعراق
المسيحي مهمش بشكل كبير جدا همم
الحكومه دائما في بغداد تعطي وعود كثير
اعطيك مثال صغير مثال صغير
صدر قانون في العراق انه حتى يحاظه على
همم او نوع من الترغيب للمسيحي في المنطقه
حتى اليهاجر نوع من التمييز الايجابي صدر
قانون انه في حال تقاعد اي مسيحي اي درجه
وظيفيه خلت من المسيحي يعين مكانه مسيحي
اخر حتى لا تنتهي لا ينتهي وجود المسيحي
في الوظائف الحكوميه
قانون صدر ومن يوم الصدر الى يومنا هذا لم
يطبق ابدا لن يطبق معه في العراق
على العراقيين يعني بشكل عام نعم احنا هذه
المشكله اللي دائما اعاني منها انه انتم
لستم وحدكم مضطهدون الجميع مضطهد انتم
لستم وحدكم الذين الذين القانون لا يحميكم
القانون لا يحمي الجميع احنا عندنا مشكله
بالعدد احنا العدد مالنا جدا قليل الوضع
ما بقي يتحمل بالنسبه لنا انه نتحمل صدمات
وضربات اكثر ما بقي يتحمل اما من يساهم في
العمل
الاغلبيه تساهم حتى
المسلمه يعني المسلمين اليوم يتحملون هذه
المسؤوليه بالنسبه اليك لا لا لا ليس ليس
المسلمون ليس المسلم انا لا اقصد المسلم
الانسان المسلم همم المسلم الاعتيادي هو
انسان طيب وهو اخي واحنا عايشين مع بعض من
1400 سنه لكن ال- طريقه الحكم في هذه
المنطقه هي خاطئه نحن ضحيه للشر الغربي
عندما
بالغباء العرب تكون نتيجته موت الشعوب لان
هنالك كميه شر في الحكومات الغربيه انا
عندما اقول غرب او شرق لا اقصد الشعوب لان
الشعوب ناس طيبين دول يقصد الحكومات
نعم
المساله واصطلاحا من سياده المطران هو
اولا حول مساله الكوتا او التمييز
الايجابي الذي يعطى للاقليات ومنهم
المسيحيون في العراق
ولنا في لبنان تاجر مديده في هذه المساله
عمرها 100 واا 160 عاما اليوم ولا اعتقد
انها همم
نجحت في هذه المساله المشكله الاساس هي
فشل الدول الحديثه او ما تسمى الحديثه في
المشرق العربي تحديدا بعد انهيار السلطنه
العثمانيه في تامين همم
العيش الحر والكريم والامن ل همم
المجموعات المتواجده فيها ومن ضمنها الماء
المسيحيون همم الاصطلاح هو لسياده المطران
عن اللقاء الاول الذي عقد
للكنائس ذات التراث السرياني ولقاء فريد
من نوعه منذ منذ مئات السنين بين الريال
والفوزوكس والكاثوليك والكلدان والاشوريون
والموارنا همم ما خلفيه هذا اللقاء وخصوصا
ان في البيان الختامي ذكر ان هذه الكنائس
هي تعبر عن شعب واحد التراث سوريا يعني
همم
قد يكون لي سياده المطران اجواء عن هذا
اللقاء واسمحي لي ان اطرح هذا السؤال
ولكن
فقط في لان الموضوع مهم كمان ما تشير اليه
ربما الى مساله
الجذور الاساسيه للجميع ربما هذا ما اردت
وهو لقاء رسمي انا سعيد رؤساء الفناء
للشاب او شابه مسيحي او مسيحيه يولد في
ارض ما في دوله ما ان يعرف ربما منذ صغره
انه لا يمكن مثلا ان يصبح رئيسا لهذه
الدوله او رئيس حكومه لهذه الدوره مع
العلم ان ربما لا ينطبق على الاردن لانها
ملكيه ولكن في دول هناك دول لا يمكن
للمواطن المسيحي ان ان ان ان يكون في هذه
المناصب وبالتالي كيف ينعكس هذا الامر على
على هذا المجتمع او على هذه الثقافه اذا
شخص مسيحي ممكن همم ما يكون عنده نفس
الحقوق ونفس الفرص همم
المواطنين الباقيين هذا معناته في مشكله
في المواطنه مشكله في العداله مشكله في
القوانين همم وتميزه وهذا احد الاسباب
لما حكيت قبل عن الهجره يعني لما تروحي
على بلاد
همم مثل كندا وامريكا
والى اخرها يعني بلاد فيها تنوع كبير
ونسمع همم عن موضوع
العداله يعني انت ممكن تكون همم شاب همم
يعني فقير همم من عائله فقيره وممكن تصير
رئيس امريكا مهما كانت خلفيتك مهما كنت
انت يعني في هذا المفهوم مفهوم العداله
همم ليس فقط باحكي عن المسيحيين لكن همم
ايس ايضا في عندنا مشكله الطبقيه همم
نرجع انه اهم شيء القانون وهمم وعدم
التمييز طيب الحديث عن القانون
على السيد جوني هناك مساله مفهوم المواطنه
في الدول العربيه ربما هل يقول كثير من
المؤرخين اليوم ان عدم دخول الدول العربيه
في ما يعرف بالحداثه الى حد ما في دساتير
هناك دساتير على مستقات من الشريعه همم من
الشرائع الدنيا يعني مثلا في لبنان كل
طائفه تحكمها شريعتها في دول عربيه اخرى
هناك الدول دين للدوله وبالتالي برايك هل
يمكن ان يكون الحل اليوم في هذه الدول هو
بفصل الدين عن شؤون الدوله او بما يعرف
العلمانيه اليوم في دول ان يحكمها مفهوم
المواطنه فقط يعني تساوي بين المواطنين
مهما كانت طوائفهم
كنت امل ان يحدث ذلك لكن الواقع يتكلم
بصوره اخرى
قديمه بان الدول العربيه ونتحدث عن انظمه
قد فشلت منذ عقود طويله في تعريف مفهوم
الدوله مفهوم الدوله الحديثه هي الدوله
التي تفصل بين الدين والدوله بمعنى اخر
انه هناك همم دين كله يتبع ديانته يستطيع
ان يتعبد وان يقوم بتاديه طقوسه وشعائره
وممارستها بشكل حر ومستقل ولا يتاثر ولا
يؤثر على الاخرين ضمن اطار معابد كل
مجموعه دينيه ايا كانت من جهه اخرى هناك
دوله ويجب ان تكون هذه الدوله مبنيه على
اسس حديثه بمعنى اخر دوله جميع المواطنين
ما معنى دوله جميع المواطنين انه المواطن
يعني بتعرفيه انت كمواطن مثلا مصري لا
يمكن ان نعرف المواطن حسب ديانته انت تعرف
الموا في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
امريكي لا تعرفين اذا كان صيني ولا اسباني
ولا مكسيكاني هذا ما يحتاج اليه العالم
العربي هذا اليوم يجب ان تكون نقل نوعيه
في احداث هذا التغيير من جهه اخرى في داخل
الجامعات المسيحيه يعني الان انا سمعت انه
في سؤال بالنسبه للبيان ما رشح من هذا
الاجتماع بالنسبه القيادات المسيحيه
السريانيه وما يتبع يتبعها والمرونيه وفي
الاخر انا اقول لك ابسط شيء فشله في
المسيحيون في هذا المشرق هو توحيد الاعيان
لا زال المسيحيون في هذه المنطقه يعني
يحتفلون باعياد الميلاد والفسح شرقي وغربي
في الحد الادنى شيء ولو كان مظهر اين اقول
يعني البعد بقول لك انه هذا شيء جوهري شيء
له يهود شيء له علاقه بقلب 1400 سنه انا
اقول لكل المسيحيين اتركوا هذه القضايا
جانب ودعونا نحتفل في الحد الادنى
بالمناسبات الدينيه القادمه علينا مع
لنشكل وحده داخليه ولو كانت مظهريه من جهه
اخرى انا اجدد على هذا الموضوع التربيه ما
التربيه ثم التربيه انا لا اقصد التربيه
الدينيه التربيه المدنيه للمواطن والمواطن
الكامله في داخل الدوله وعدم التبادل
تغيير شكل الدول الموجوده حاليا يعني هذا
ما هو هذا ما يمكن ان يساهم في حل ربما
مساله تفريغ هذا هذه الدول من مكوناتها
الثقافيه المتنوعه ومن هم المسيحيون طيب
ساسال حضره المطران حضره المطران اليوم
همم ما رايك بطرح حل العلمانيه للدول
العربيه او تغيير شكل النظام في الدول
العربيه كي تضمن لكل المواطنين مهما
كانتيانتهم ان يكونوا سواسيه امام القانون
هل برايك هذا حل وماذا تجيب على مساله
الوحده الداخليه التي يشكك فيها ايضا
في منطقه في هذه المنطقه بصراحه انا مع
المدنيه ولست مع العلمانيه يعني اكو فرق
شويه بين المدنيه والعلمانيه العلم هي
تاخذنا الى مكانات ابعد بكثير همم يمكن
تضرب حتى في خصوصيه الانسان وكرامه
الانسان لكن انا مع المدنيه لان لا علاقه
للدين مع الدوله ابدا لا يوجد اي علاقه
الدوله يجب ان تكون دوله مؤسسات الدوله من
واجبات توفير الماء الكهربائي الانترنت
ال- ال- الصحه المدارس للجميع وتوفير
والبنيه التحتيه تمام مثلا توفر الكهرباء
للكنيسه للجامع للكباريه للمدرسه للمستشفى
لاي مؤسسه موجوده كاش ما تكون هذا شغل
الدوله تنظر الى المواطن ان هو مواطن ما
شغل الدوله انه تشتغل رب العالمين او الله
على الارض هذا مو شغله متى ما ربطنا الدين
بالدوله همم كانت نتيجته ما يحدث في هذه
المجتمعات التي تطور اليوم عالم ثالث طيب
على الوحده المسيحيه المسيحيه باختصار
حضرتك
عن الوحده المسيحيه حقيقه هذا موضوع
الكثير في الداخل يوجد وحده حقيقيه نحن
نحترم بعضنا البعض نحب بعضنا البعض هذا
ليس كلام وردي انما حقيقه واكبر دليل
الاجتماع الذي تحدث عنه الاخ اللي هو همم
دعى الينه وقداسه البطريرك الثاني
للكنائس التي تنتمي الى الجذور والتراث
السرياني الواحد وحتى هنا اليوم نحن نعيش
في العراق بين كنائس مسيحيه يوجد حب كبير
مساله العيد ومساله مخجله متعبه هو مساله
تقويم هي ليست مساله عقيده ابدا يجب ان
تحل وان شاء الله على هذا الموضوع
ان يتخلصوا من هذا الشعور بالخوف ربما وان
يتمسكوا بالبقاء في اوطانهم همم التعليم
والتربيه وايضا اا القوانين
وايضا همم الفرص العمل همم والاقتصاد
ويجب على الحكومات
والانظمه العربيه تغيير منهج توفير خدمات
لشعوبها طيب شكرا لك رنا الشهر
تحدثنا عن العلمانيه تحدثنا عن دول
المدنيه برايك هل هل سياسي لهذه المساله
فقط سياسي ام ان هناك ايضا ربما مشكله
اخرى قد تصدم بهذه المجتمعات وهي مشكله
عقليات المشكله السياسي هو هو طارق على
المشكله ابعد الثقافي باي معنى معنى ان
الذي طرح في همم دور المسيحيين السياسي لم
يكن يطرح في اثناء الدول الاسلاميه
التاريخيه من الخلافات العباسيه والامويه
والى
طرح في القرنين 18 وال 19
بفعل ما يسمى المساله الشرقيه وتدخل الدول
الاوروبيه في السلطنه العثمانيه بعد ما
باتت هذه السلطنه رجلا فاصبح الموضوع
الديني موضوعا سياسيا وجغرافيا سياسيا او
جيو بوليتيكي بامتياز
ولسوء الحظ ان الدول التي
ولدت بعد الانتدابات والاستعمارات في هذه
المنطقه وبعد الاستقلال لن تستطيع ان تقدم
نموذجا يدير التعدديه بشكل صالح سواء كان
ذلك في العراق ام في سوريا ام في لبنان ام
في فلسطين المحتله ام ايه في مصر وهل مجره
مع العلم ان هناك نموذج اخر ولد في
السنوات الاخيره لاداره هذه التعدديه
ورايناها في دوله عربيه واضحه هي السودان
لا ننسى ان هناك
نموذج للتعدديه
حلوه التقسيم لكن اشير الى ان الفيل داخل
هذه الغرفه في السودان رغم التقسيم
ذا الطابع مسيحي في جنوب السودان وفي سهل
نينوى كان هناك مطالبات في نوع من التقسيط
وطبعا في الجزيره السوريه وفي لبنان هناك
مطالبات مديده وعمرها
انا اظن ان الحل في اداره هذه التعدديه
اليوم هي نماذج مركبه
موجوده في كل دول العالم تدير التعدديه
بشكل صالح دون ان ندخل في الكوته المركزيه
التي تولد الخلافات بشكل اكثر
مساله اداره التعدديه
المسيحيين في هذا المشرق ان يرفض كل فكره
لاستقلاليه همم سياديه بمعنى استقلال بناء
دوله واستقلاليتها هذا امر يعني انا
باعتبره جد خطير
ولدينا نموذج لذلك في لبنان ماذا ماذا جار
منذ 160 عاما من 1860 وحتى يومنا هذا
للمسيحيه في لبنان سوى التراجعكم الى
الوراء مع احتفاظ التغمى الدينيه الكنسيه
وايضا السياسيه الدينيه السياسيه
الاقتصاديه الراسماليه بامساكها بخناق
الدوله
والتاثير سلبا على المسيحيين والمسلمين
وهذا ما نراه الان في لبنان انا باعتقادي
انه يجب الحفاظ على خصوصيه المسيحيين
كمسيحيين من النواحي الثقافيه الدينيه
الروحيه الى اخره ولكن لمن اطار السياق
الحياه اليومي مع اخوانهم المسلمين
انه لا نستطيع ان نغطي الشمس بالغربال
الواقع الذي مفروض عليه تاريخيا شئنا ام
ابينا ان نعيش معا ويجب ان نستمر في العيش
المشترك الى ابد الابدين حتى يوم القيامه
ان قامت القيامه مع الاحتفاظ يعني مختلف
مختلف
اين اين
اختلاف ابدا
اقول الدوله المركبه تحترم الدوله
لو سمحت اعطيك الكلمه الاخيره الحقيقه انا
اريد ان اخدم منه ان احنا نصلي انه هذه
البلدان التي في الشرق التي اليوم صارت
تسمى عربيه وهي اغلب ليست بعربيه نصلي ان
الله يلهم حكام انه يقدر الانسان يحترم
المواطن كمواطن تكون المدنيه هي الحاكم
والقانون هو السيد الذي يحكم الجميع والذي
يجب ان يحترم من قبل الجميع والذي يعطي
حقوق الجميع وعليه واجبات من الجميع متى
ما وصلنا الى هذه المرحله
سيدي اعتذر لان الوقت انتهى بهذه الفكره
متى ما وصلنا متى ما وصلنا الى هذه الفكره
هذاك الوقت راح نقدر نقول احنا راح نقدر
نستمر في هذا الشرق العزيز الذي هو ارضنا
وارض ابانا واجدادنا وان شاء الله ما
اشكركم وانا خايفه ممنوع لا نهايه له نترك
لك ولك حريه التفكير وحريه الاختيار ابقى
دائما على فخاذون كاتخوا مونت كارلو
الدوليه تحياتي
[موسيقى]